hey youtubers is Charlie we finally got
a full-blown crossover this is gonna be
my flash episode eight video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet let's see who's really the
fastest so many comic book things in
this episode it was so wonderful and
what about that Hall of Justice they
even lit it up at night just so that you
would focus on it Super Friends unite so
just a quick reminder there is a flash
ring giveaway that's going on right now
that's right I brought the flash rings
back to the giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video make sure you turn
alerts on so you don't miss anything but
let's do top 10 WTF in comic book Easter
eggs so number 10 that final scene from
Supergirl if they literally just like
took a scene from the flash and tacked
it onto the end of Supergirl so it was
kind of a WTF but I understand why they
did it like they're still trying to
logistical e-fit Supergirl into the CW
universe just because behind the scenes
is so complicated so I think that next
year it'll be a little more integrated
you'll see more Supergirl characters
come in for whatever the crossover is
going to be but the other big reason is
that the dominators are only invading
earth one but they do explain the Cara's
earth is earth 38 so confirmed earth 38
the 38 doesn't seem like an Easter Egg
to me right now because it doesn't refer
to any specific Supergirl stuff like
Justice League number 38 isn't a
Supergirl story the flash number 38
isn't a Supergirl story so they might
have some other hidden relevance behind
that 38 number but they did explain that
the dominators of supergirls universe
would come back in the back half of the
season
so these dominators are Justin Barrie
and Oliver's universe which kind of
explains why it's only a three-way
crossover but it would have been cool to
see the flash help out with cyborg
Superman either way number 9 Kid Flash
is getting faster and faster they just
want to get him ready I think for the
back half of the season even though
Cisco gets really pissed off they do sit
you know like don't tell him about the
suit so Wally will end up in that suit
sooner rather than later
speaking of which number 8 Wally save
late in the game they had this storyline
in the episode that felt a little
disingenuous like iris is like don't go
nobody tell him that he's awesome
everybody tell him that he sucks even HR
is like nope when Wally asked him to
train him the first time the second time
he relents
but even if wall-e didn't have powers he
would still want to help out I felt like
this was like the weirdest storyline in
the episode don't tell Wally he's
awesome but he does help out it's a
great takedown it's like a really simple
seat like you know he helps out calls
himself Kid Flash and then gets taken
out by Supergirl so he'll probably be
back by the midseason finale definitely
by episode 10 so I think we're all happy
about that like we want a kid flash back
in the game like this whole early season
of the flash this Wally storyline has
been drugged out way too much but number
seven aliens Oh something out of a
Ridley Scott nightmare I like the alien
shout out so the dominators invade and
they learn from a Lyla that this
happened in the 1950s but the weird part
of this is that the government wants to
handle it now it's not just Argus it's
like the larger government that Argus is
a part of so Lyla learns a little bit of
the politicking but the president who's
totally down to go after the dominators
gets yanked so that kind of sets off the
mind-control storyline but number six
flash isn't going to set things out of
course he's not going to set things out
so they immediately cut to Star City I
like the way they cut that edit where
Oliver and Diggle are chasing down
vigilante if you haven't been watching
arrow this season he is one of the few
villains on the show now that Oliver is
going after
so Barry saves them in the exact same
way that he grabbed the boomerangs from
the first arrow flash crossover they
were actually a couple references in
moments in this episode that called back
to that first one like when Supergirl
got mind-controlled you're not the first
superhero to get mind control like Barry
did during flash versus arrow number
five they go to meet at a giant
warehouse that Barry just happens to
have Thea says you should do something
with this but it's like an empty
warehouse but then when they show the
exterior it's the Hall of Justice that
they have been putting in the poster
promos in the Hall of Justice is
actually from the Superfriends cartoon
it's where the Justice League
headquarters are so you could call them
the Superfriends you could call them TV
Justice League it's much closer to TV
Justice League but this is them like
full-on doing it especially when they
lit it up at night so that also kind of
reminded me of a charged plan to turn
STAR Labs into a museum like he was
getting ready to pitch them when the
episode started so that might also be
leading to the flash Museum they
just like combine the Hall of Justice
with the flash Museum because Barry saw
it when he traveled back to save his
mother in season 1 so eventually we have
to get the flash Museum it's the Hall of
Justice that's the new thing we never
thought that we were going to get so now
that building exists so just imagine how
they're going to use it next year
by the time we get to next year they'll
also probably a lot cooler stuff inside
there too they all introduce each other
the legends arrive Diggle has his funny
joke moment you know the reason I don't
take drugs is because I'm worried I'll
see weird stuff like he threw up when
Barry saved him so Diggle always has the
greatest reactions when weird stuff
happens but number 4 really big deal
Barry's future message is revealed the
future flash cannot be trusted for some
reason causes like some other big
flashpoint change I think what they
meant to say they were a little
confusing about the way they explained
the war in the future I've gone back in
time changed things my understanding is
that future Barry was just explaining
flashpoint the first flashpoint the one
that we saw happened on the flash to rip
hunter but this is older Barry and it
also ties up with the future newspaper
flash vanishes in crisis so now they
brought back the flash newspaper we
haven't seen it in a while iris West
isn't the author anymore so there are
changes it just reflects the changes
because of flashpoint so now Barry's in
the [ __ ] with the rest of the team
Diggle is pissed when he learns out
about baby Sarah now being baby John I
mean he's happy that his son exists but
knowing that he had a daughter and Barry
just changed that just completely sucks
so I feel like most of the team's
reactions to Barry are justified they
just wanted to create conflict so that
Barry would not go get MC so that he
could save them later so you can argue
the logic of their decisions but I feel
like it's okay to be mad at Barry but
Cisco did have that funny line where he
said apparently now it's illegal to be
mad at Barry number three team flash
versus Supergirl she just laughs at all
of their attacks like they tickle her
just completely remind you how
invincible she is compared to the others
so they might bring the kryptonite ring
in at some point like Batman has the
kryptonite ring in case Superman ever
goes nuts
so given more team-ups I wouldn't be
surprised if Oliver finds a way to make
a kryptonite ring Barry feels like he'd
be
- hopeful for something like that like
all my friend Cara she would never do
something to hurt me
Oliver is the pessimistic one he plans
for the future so if anybody's getting a
kryptonite ring it would be Oliver but
that almost reminds me like talking
about rings I'm doing the flash ring
giveaway Cisco also tells the atom that
he wants to upgrade his suit but he's
like later after we're done with this so
if you thought the atom suit looked kind
of bogus if you didn't like it in season
one they're gonna make it way cooler now
so number two is Oliver and Barry versus
the team like an evil Justice League
team up this is as close to crime
syndicate as I think we're gonna get for
a little while so Oliver and Barry
versus the crime syndicate Barry takes
down a bunch of the Ariel ones with the
lightning throw Oliver takes down the
melee fighters makes sense then Wally
comes in helps take them out and I love
the way flash took out the mind-control
device by phasing Supergirl through him
or essentially he phased so that she
just ran right through him the number
one of course is them getting beamed up
into a Dominator ship setting the stage
for the matrix like arrow 100th episode
so that'll explain the dreamlike state
that they're in they'll all be in these
pods I don't know how much of the
episode they're going to spend in that
dream but it's their hundredth episode
so that big speech that Barry gave to
Oliver it was a really awesome speech
about how he's not a god it's not his
fault the time changes everybody makes
choices that changed the timeline but
when he said I would do anything to be
able to go back and change what happened
to my mother I felt so powerless so
helpless of course they're setting that
up for the arrow episode so they're
totally going to pay off all that Oliver
stuff like he explains how his father
killed himself in the other passenger
and the life raft so that Oliver could
survive all that is going to be followed
up on in the air 100th episode so even
though this is just the first part of
the crossover they've done a good job of
setting things up that they'll pay off
in the next two episodes but for those
of you asking about future flash stuff
so they were talking about the war I
think they'll follow up on that and
it'll have something to do with the
Savatage storyline so like each of the
shows will take little bits from this
big crossover and it'll inform what's
happening with their storylines like
Sara talks about not being able to go
back in time to
say floral they're going to follow up
with that on legends obviously arrow has
all the hundredth episode stuff and that
will spin into Laurel stuff as well but
for those of you asking what that future
war is you could think of that as future
flash from the comics who just decides
that he can't be trusted so he has to go
back in time to kill himself obviously
that's not going to happen on the TV
show it's just meant to be like the
worst possible thing that could ever
happen to them so like Oliver said that
people's choices always change the
future that's going to have to happen on
the flash like they're going to have to
find a way to change what's happening
this season to make a better future so
it's always fun when you know that
things are going to complete [ __ ] okay
well we know where we're ending up so we
have to try to avoid that now but let me
know what was your favorite moment from
the episode I feel like Oliver and Barry
versus the team was probably my favorite
they opened the episode with that so
naturally it was like the biggest part
of the episode but let's do it this way
everybody leave a like if you want to
see a future crossover versus like a
crime syndicate for them to actually do
something like that but I do feel like
in a future season they might do
Manhunters something like big enough
like Warworld Mongol to merit the need
for all these people to team up it has
to be someone big someone that Barry
couldn't just take down himself using
his speed force powers but get hype for
arrow 100th episode tomorrow Deathstroke
is going to lay the smackdown I'm so
excited about Deathstroke there's so
much other stuff happening in the
episode too I mean if you're a really
big fan of Black Canary arrow stuff in
the comics they're going to be doing a
lot of that stuff but really like
Deathstroke like all the people that we
haven't seen in forever
seeing Oliver's father seeing a couple
other people we haven't seen in a while
I'm expecting Tommy but you know pretty
much every big cast member they've ever
had on arrow is supposed to be on I
don't know about Roy though I haven't
heard anything about him guest starring
I haven't seen him in any of the promos
so he would be the big surprise like if
Rowe showed up but what's going to
happen is I'll post another bonus video
tomorrow morning I'll post a Rick and
Morty video in then arrow 100th episode
so there should be three videos but if I
don't think I'm gonna get that Rick and
Morty video out I'll just let you guys
know when I post that first one well you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my part one video that
explained
what's going on this week what to watch
out for and you can click here for my
Game of Thrones Season 7 teaser trailer
so thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you